have to tell you you are truly one of
the most entertaining people to watch in
movies on tv
jackass forever felt really nostalgic to
me honestly i had such a good time
watching it
what made you decide now was the right
time to do another jackass film
i in 2018 i you know i've been writing
for
ideas for 10 years not knowing if we'd
ever do another one but in 2018 i get
this overwhelming feeling that i wanted
to do another
and uh when that happens the only way to
satiate it is to get out and shoot the
film
so
i talked to jeff tremaine and he was
down and the rest of the cast had been
wanting to make another film since we
shot the last one so they were more than
down
so this is all you once you say go
another movie gets made
i was the hold up yes yeah gotcha so how
does your family handle this and i want
to know i know you have kids do they
think you're cool dad
no
i don't think uh my kids think i'm so
cool
well my young kids like
uh
my oldest daughter you know she enjoys
the films but my young kids don't see
the films
so i'm just the uh
bad joke telling embarrassing dad
are you excited to show them the films
when they're old enough
when they're old enough but that's gonna
be years yeah it's gonna be a little bit
i love that um did you have any
reservations about doing this because
obviously you know you've talked about
the stunt and we got to see it watching
this movie uh of a bull charging out you
said this is you know the the hardest
you've been hit were there any
reservations when it came to making
these stunts
um well you get a little nervous about
two or three days outside of doing the
stunt
but on the day of
like i'm chomping at the bit to do the
stunt like i just want to shoot it
and i'm just jeff i'm gonna go sit in my
car
and when you have the set ready please
call me and when the bull is ready to
come out of the chute call me in because
i don't want to get there and stand
around and think about it yeah right
it's it's much easier if you just get in
there and do it
yeah do you have a hard time you know
watching that stunt back on film with
knowing you know that you you you got
hit pretty hard you had to go through
serious recovery
uh
no it doesn't it doesn't uh
do anything to me
mentally to watch it uh i
you know
it it's it was a rough recovery but it
was great footage so i get it
that's great footage you feeling good
though now yeah i'm totally recovered
okay that's a good feeling um is there i
can just imagine like you know coming up
with all the different stunts is there a
stunt that you wanted to do that you
planned and then you or other people on
your team were just like you know we
can't do this it's too much or is there
something that you still want to do but
you think it's too extreme
no
because
we have 12 people somebody's going to
shoot it
somebody's going to do the idea
right
because people are so competitive about
getting footage we all love each other
but people are very competitive about
getting footage if someone gets good
footage then that person is like oh now
i need good footage and that works very
well for the movie
that worked so well did it feel like a
reunion getting back together with your
crewman obviously you had really fun
like
celebs coming on too and that was cool
but did it feel like a reunion or did it
feel different this time around
no it felt like a a family reunion you
wanted to attend
you know it's just a great big
dysfunctional family and nothing is as
fun as shooting a jackass film yeah okay
so is there another one in the works
what do you think
we don't know half-assed stuntmen are
terrible long-term planners so there may
be there may not be but it's possible
that's awesome hey congrats on the film
it was really nice getting to talk to
you thank you not talking to you
you